today we have finally reached an
agreement between the EU and stokey we
needed to ensure that each and every
migrant arriving in Europe will be
treated individually in other words that
our agreement complies with all EU and
international law it excludes any kind
of collective expansions the eur
agencies and the UNHCR will be invited
to participate in this process today we
have a balanced proposal that takes on
both Cypriot concerns finally on timing
we agreed that all irregular migrants
coming from turkey into Greek islands
from the sunday the twentieth of March
will be returned to turkey some I think
this agreement is a silver bullet but
reality is more complex it is just one
pillar of the European comprehensive
strategy and can work only if the other
pillars are also implemented this
includes strengthening the u.s. external
borders keeping the Western Balkans
route closed and getting back to
Schengen we agreed that in order to
discourage human smugglers and in order
to encourage legal migration we have a
balanced approach turkey will be getting
all those who are crossing to aging
islands illegally but meanwhile Europe
will receive the same number of legal
migrants from Turkey so this is a very
fair and encouraging steps for Refugees
as well those who are looking for their
future also the burden sharing is
important and we agreed that the cost
and burden sharing will be also in a
fair manner
you